so guys in terms of auditioning for the
collection was there anything that you
did differently for for these two that
you didn't do maybe prior auditions what
was it that sort of did you just John -
enter that they just pull you in no the
audition for the collector the first one
that we shot and that was like I
auditioned on a Wednesday got the job
one Thursday was on a plane Friday was
shooting Monday so I was like a backup
to the back to the back that's the way
you know my my audition was I think just
like any other except that the content
is different for horror films you're
there's a lot of imagination in any
audition situation but this you're like
watching your best friend die in front
of you and then you're you know the
scene is probably you running but you're
standing in a small room so there's no
running involved so it's a lot of like
strange maneuvering of like the
physicality of this kind of stuff but
Joseph Middleton the casting director
did me this like a huge favor of just
just like told me to sit down and was
like ask me for questions and got me
crying and then put me in a dark room
put the call back at least and put me in
a dark room I was like just stay here
for like ten minutes until I bring them
in and I was like that what's going on
I'm so confused
and yeah they just want to see you
crying I guess so I took me back in the
room and I said a couple of lines while
I was sobbing and and yeah that was it
it's kind of messed up but so is the
movie
you